well the midterms used to be like boring
didn't they
you know the midterm elections used to
be like boring didn't they give it
remember what they were people say
midterms they say what is that what is
it right now it's like the hottest thing
it's the hottest thing the midterms are
really more like spring break for older
children a crazed group who see nothing
but evil and Trump think Dems gone wild
well now they're even stripping oh like
your life depends on it
vote obvi Acadie porter's new campaign
headquarters obviate Gil Cisneros
campaign headquarters today and we will
be at a Viet UC Irvine that's an actual
adult so exactly two years ago these
kids got their blind rage on and never
took it off there was no pleasing them
especially if they're well-off enough
not to be affected by a great economy or
job market they don't need Trump the way
the rest of America does and Trump does
make a great target
he's a law-and-order guy defending the
process behind Borders national into
missed domestic security it's one word
boundaries boundaries exist to frame the
path toward a goal Wyoming without
fences is just another chunk of the
planet that fences and you get order and
logic you need them for a country's
identity and you need them as laws which
allow people to lead free lives without
harm what's the problem well any Law &
Order stance becomes heartless because
the left separates the process which is
enforcing laws from the results which is
creating order so military cops ice
they're just big meanies it's childish
to pretend that laws don't lead to
better lives but it works so today's
vote is about adults versus those with a
teenage view of the world and even
though the kids know that without
grownups they'd be dead who cares
because the adults will always be around
hurting feelings making rules imposing
limits making life possible kids just
have a hard time forgiving grown-ups for
making life impossible your perfect
example Dana bill de blasio as the mayor
of New York I call him stupid Zilla Oh
got it okay I know
there wasn't a security bed already made
for him by by Giuliani and then
Bloomberg New York would be in chaos
mainly because his ideal ideology
forbids being prokop Rollo law and order
so he Eretz this so he can be even more
progressive right and then you can see
it eroding he's in his second term so
you can you can absolutely see that I
think Democrats are going to have to
really sit down and try to figure out
what are they for on immigration yeah
cuz what present aside from building the
wall president Trump's policies are very
much like Barack Obama's yeah it's not
all that different there the
deportations the use of ice that's up
family separation we've already talked
about that like obviously that was like
a course correction on that one but
other than that the Democrats are gonna
have to figure out what can we be for
because they will not win in races where
Republicans have won if they don't
figure out what they're gonna say on it
what should they do Laura well I just
have to say this Reuters right now just
could get into the how the media has
been so in the bag the mainstream media
so in the back to the Democrats right
now on Reuters there is a headline that
says whatever the results tonight bado
set to emerge victorious if you lose you
win if you win you win I think the way
we have to look at this is people do
like divided government like they like a
check on Trump is a little too much here
well we'll try it for a few years where
there's a check on him if things don't
go well then maybe they're gonna throw
that party out I mean people are in the
mood to kind of give give report cards
but I'm telling you Jesse and Greg on
the substance you cannot argue with
Trump's policies winning across the
board right track wrong track by the way
Juan has been trending upward the past
year and that's better than they were in
2010 so maybe that's why his approval
rating is so low well I think now it's
like 51 I just read it's not 51 but you
know to your point to the tried as a
monologue I just want to say as the
oldest person sitting here I want to
stand up for the young people because
guess what they're the only one voting
for you in terms of the young people
tonight what we know is that in Georgia
state like Georgia four times
the rate of turnout in 2014 in Texas in
Nevada five times Greg in Arizona three
times so what you see is young people
more engaged this is goes to the top of
your monologue which is Trump has made
midterms more relevant more interesting
more essential for Americans and I think
we engage people in the political
process who previously thought
at midterms or Oh elections and a lot of
those folks from the Democratic
perspective thought Hillary Clinton's
gonna win yeah so why bother
yeah Jesse yeah I mean Trump makes
everything hot right now I mean the
economy Twitter trade liars leakers and
liberals that looks flying off the
shelves also some negative things you
know we now know how hard the Special
Counsel is we know who Jim Acosta is
unfortunately but if you put Trump's
name in front of everything it just
makes it good for instance I only eat
Trump steaks I didn't even know what a
steak was until I saw true aren't
pathetic you're just trying to angle for
free steak
yeah send them over to Fox please yes